on retrouve notre correspondant Universe
qui nous donne plus d'infos
si les autorités ukrainiennes disent que
quelques 30% de l'infrastructure
d'approvisionnement en électricité du
pays a été endommagée suite aux frappe
russe essentiellement celle de lundi ce
jeudi la compagnie nationale
d'électricité ou kremergo dit que
maintenant la connexion est restaurée
sur tout le pays la compagnie a remercié
les Ukrainiens d'avoir de pas eux-mêmes
économiser et réduit leur consommation
en électricité ce qui a permis au réseau
de continuer à fonctionner malgré les
dégâts et ils espèrent ne pas avoir
besoin d'avoir recours à des coupures de
courant dans les jours qui viennent il y
en a eu sur plusieurs régions d'Ukraine
ces derniers jours apparemment
maintenant selon ukrainergo c'est fini
et les réparations sont encore en cours
bien sûr la Russie a expressément dit
avoir l'intention de continuer à essayer
de cibler l'infrastructure de génération
d'électricité du pays alors on va voir
si ils arrivent à le faire avec c'est
dans les jours qui viennent certainement
ils ont continué leur tentative sur la
région de Kiev ce jeudi matin au petit
matin c'était trois frappes de drones
kamikazes sur la région près de la ville
de Makari à l'ouest de Kiev qui ont
selon les autorités locales atteint leur
cible des cibles d'infrastructures il ne
précise pas lesquels ils disent que il
n'y a pas de
victimes parmi la population civile en
revanche des frappes ailleurs en Ukraine
pendant la nuit de mercredi à jeudi on
fait des victimes parmi les populations
civiles notamment dans le sud du pays à
mikolif et dans l'Est à actif 4 auprès
de donuts